hey 42 here the ability to harness
energy from the world around us has
quite literally fueled the technological
development of the human race for
millennia and every time we've got our
hands on a newer shinier more powerful
way of utilizing energy it's acted as a
kind of level up for our species
for our ancient ancestors energy
extraction was a life or death kind of
situation that went no further than
eating plants and animals in order to
stay alive and it wasn't until we
finally mastered the tricky business of
fire that things started to pick up for
the human race for the first time we
were able to release stored energy at
will to keep ourselves warm fend off
predators and cook food that had
previously been too difficult to digest
eventually we figured out how to harness
the energy of other animals without
first sticking a spit through them by
putting them to work in our fields and
using them for transportation
we learned how to capture the energy of
the wind in ships sails enabling us to
cross oceans and colonized the world
at some point a bright spark realized
the water running downhill generated
energy we could use through water wheels
to grind our grain and power saw and
textile mills
next we got our heads around steam power
which catalyzed the industrial
revolution
and these days we extract huge
quantities of fossil fuels from beneath
the earth to light our homes and power
our cars
these different ways of generating
energy are so diverse
it's easy to forget they all come from a
common source
the sun
when sunlight shines on the earth some
is captured and converted into chemical
energy by plants
by eating or burning those plants we're
simply converting that energy into a
form we can readily use whether for
nutrition heat or just to get high
fossil fuels those incredibly convenient
but annoyingly environmentally
unfriendly sources of energy that so
much of our modern worlds depends on
are nothing more than the remains of
plants and animals deposited over
millions of years
even water wheels and ship sales are
ultimately powered by solar energy
liquid water only exists here on earth
in the first place thanks to heat from
the sun which also causes water to
evaporate rise into the atmosphere and
fall back to earth as rain
the mechanical energy of water rushing
downhill in streams and rivers that
powers the humble water wheel is
essentially stored energy from sunlight
the same is true for wind energy which
is created by differences in air
temperature and density that form as the
sun warms the ground to varying degrees
it isn't quite true to say all the
energy we use here on earth comes
directly from the sun
icelandic favorite geothermal energy is
derived from forces at play during the
formation of the planet and the decay of
radioactive particles in the earth's
core
nuclear energy comes from splitting
atoms and tidal energy is created by the
interplay of gravity between the earth
sun and moon
but at least for now they make up a
small percentage of the total energy we
use with energy generated by sunlight
being dominant
as our civilization continues to grow
more advanced
our energy needs will increase
that's partly because there'll simply be
more of us almost 10 billion by 2050
according to current estimations
and partly because the things we do
require more energy with every passing
year
with our computers tablets and mobile
phones we're all using more energy more
of the time and as a society we're using
our ever-increasing technological
capabilities
to make some seriously power-hungry toys
take fugaku which sounds like a kind of
sushi but it's actually the world's
fastest supercomputer
it uses enough energy to power 20 000
homes when pushed to its prodigious
limits
then there's the large hadron collider
at cern in switzerland which has an
annual energy consumption equivalent to
that used by three hundred thousand
homes
in the last two hundred years or so the
total energy consumption of mankind has
increased almost two thousand five
hundred percent
compared to a population increase of
about seven hundred percent
and we're showing no signs of slowing
this trends down anytime soon but
there's a problem
the energy available to us here on earth
is not an infinite resource
and sooner or later
we're going to start running out
earth overshoot day is calculated as the
date each year
when humanity's resource consumption
exceeds the levels the earth is capable
of regenerating the following year
it isn't an exact science but it's a
good illustration of how much we're
eating into unsustainable reserves of
things like fossil fuels think of it
like a doomsday clock but for key
resources instead of the total
annihilation of mankind when it was
first calculated in 1987
earth overshoot day landed on the 23rd
of october
since then the date has been steadily
creeping forward each year and
in 2019
overshoot day came at the end of july in
short our energy needs are rapidly
increasing whilst our energy reserves
are slowly decreasing
this means at some point in the future
there's going to come a time when the
energy available to us here on earth
simply isn't going to cut it anymore
so what happens then
well it just so happens that in 1960 a
man named freeman dyson asked himself
that very same question and the
conclusion he came to was both
startlingly ambitious and incredibly
simple instead of collecting our star's
energy second hand in the form of fossil
fuels or wind power
we just cut out the middleman and
harvest all the energy we need directly
from the sun and that's exactly what you
can do in stellaris galaxy command
who've kindly sponsored this video i
tell you i've been absolutely glued to
this game for the past few weeks i've
always been a fan of paradox
interactives games i've put hundreds of
hours into solaris on pc in stellaris i
always enjoy building mega structures
such as dyson spheres which is what this
video is all about and in stellaris
galaxy command you start out with a huge
space station nexus which is your very
own mini mega structure if you like but
you can carefully upgrade with shipyards
research institutes decorative items and
much much more i have to say one of my
favorite parts about this game is the
intergalactic shootouts because the
graphics and sound effects are fantastic
there's an entire galaxy out there to
explore you can colonize other planets
forge alliances and trade on the
galactic market there's so much to
explore in this game that you should get
started today so click the link in the
description to download and play
stellaris galaxy command and if you use
my code 42 you'll get these amazing
in-game bonuses 144 speed ups 5 flagship
materials and 200 credits don't miss
this one guys
now you might be picturing mile upon
mile of solar panels in some dusty
desert here on planet earth at this
point but the thing is only a tiny
fraction of the total energy produced by
the sun ever comes our way
stars are after all spherical and they
radiate energy pretty much equally in
all directions
meaning any earthbound solar panels no
matter how large and efficient
will never come close to tapping the
entirety of the sun's total energy
output
if we want to do that dyson realized
we're going to need to get a hell of a
lot closer and build something much
much bigger
the technology he conceived to harvest
all of the sun's energy is today known
as a dyson sphere
a megastructure that would completely
encompass the sun inside a giant shell
now
fair warning we're about to enter that
strange grey area that exists between
science fiction and science future here
current estimates suggest we won't be
capable of building such a structure for
a few thousand years yet
but some scientists believe dyson's
fears of some variety are a logical
perhaps even inevitable step in the
technological evolution of any advanced
civilization the kind of dyson sphere
most often depicted is a solid
shell-like megastructure that completely
envelops its star
with the interior surface lined with
solar panels that would absorb 100 of
the total energy output of that star
which is about 385 yatta watts in the
case of the sun
okay so a yottawatt sounds kind of made
up but to put that figure into
perspective it's about 22 trillion times
humanity's total power consumption today
that means if we were to imagine every
single one of the 250 billion stars in
our galaxy was home to an advanced
civilization with equivalent energy
needs to our own
a single dyson sphere surrounding our
sun would provide enough energy to power
all of them indefinitely in fact even if
we added a trillion civilizations from
the stars of our neighboring galaxy
andromeda into the mix our solitary
dyson sphere would still have enough
energy to power every single one of them
without even breaking a sweat
everlasting energy with enough left over
to lend to the neighbors sign me up
the problem is even as far as
hypothesized solar megastructures go a
dyson sphere would be kinda tricky to
build
the radius of these theoretical spheres
is typically assumed to be one
astronomical unit
that's about the distance between the
earth and the sun with the idea being
that sunlight hitting the interior of
the dyson sphere would be of the same
intensity as we're used to here on earth
meaning we could happily live on it but
let's take a second to think about how
ridiculously big this thing would be
we're talking a colossal sphere with a
radius of 93 million miles completely
encircling the sun not to mention
encompassing the orbits of mercury and
venus
such a megastructure would have a
surface area about 550 million times
larger than that of earth assuming we
are able to make the whole interior
surface habitable which would require
overcoming several technical challenges
that we won't even get into here and
that we spread everyone out with a
similar population density to that which
we currently have on earth
there would be room for almost four
quadrillion people to live there if you
wanted to take a road trip around the
equator to take in the sights even
traveling at 100 miles per hour non-stop
in your fancy car of the future
it would take you almost 700 years to
get back to where you started hell even
traveling at the speed of light it would
take you almost an hour so yeah this
thing would be on the large side
so large in fact that we would have to
literally dismantle every single planet
in our solar system just to get our
hands on enough raw materials to build
it
putting aside the morality of destroying
the solar system in our endless hunt for
energy
i mean we're basically doing the same
thing here on earth so i'm sure we'll
get over it when the time comes
even if we tore up all the planets
including the gas giants
we would only have enough materials to
make a dyson sphere between 8 and 20
centimeters thick depending on the
density of the outer shell oh and
speaking of materials
as of today no building material known
to man would even come close to being
strong enough it's also worth mentioning
that something this big would be an
absolute asteroid magnet so we're almost
certainly going to have to install a
screen protector right out of the box
now you might be wondering what exactly
we would do with 22 trillion times as
much energy as we need right now
and that's a fairly good question
first up we'll naturally have greatly
increased energy needs by the time we're
technologically advanced enough to
actually build a dyson sphere so we'll
be able to power all that lovely future
tech no problem i'm sure the ps5 million
is going to be quite the energy hog but
even taking that into account it's
likely we're going to have a little bit
of headroom scientists science fiction
authors and under-qualified youtubers
have all spent time pondering just what
the human race could do with
near-limitless energy
and it turns out the possibilities are
well near limitless
it's even been theorized we could use
dyson sphere-like megastructures as
solar system scale engines designed to
complete specific tasks
one such engine known as a matriasca
brain would use a series of nested dyson
spheres to funnel the total energetic
output of its parent star
towards one single purpose
computation
some people have hypothesized that a
solar system-sized computer drawing on
this much energy
would have the capability to challenge
the very laws underpinning our universe
whilst others have theorized that it
would almost certainly be able to run
crisis
probably the most popular hypothesis is
that a matriarchal brain will be able to
run perfect simulations of human minds
inside entire virtual worlds perhaps
even universes allowing us if we wanted
to to digitize the entire human race
making ourselves an entirely new and
effectively immortal species in the
process who knows we may even be living
inside the memory banks of a matriarchal
brain right now
okay so all this is really interesting
and everything but why should we care
i mean even if dyson's fears really are
the inevitable energetic evolution of
mankind none of us are ever going to
come close to seeing one these things
won't be built by humans for thousands
of years and cryogenic freezing is
probably not to mention
obscenely expensive
so we'll all be long dead by then
but
it turns out dyson spheres are actually
extremely relevant to the human race
right now not because we have a
snowflakes chance in hell of building
one anytime soon but because someone
else
might if you've watched my video on why
we haven't found aliens yet
you'll know one of the biggest
challenges facing our hunt for
extraterrestrial life is the frankly
inconvenient size of the universe there
are so many places to look and all of
them are so damn far away that searching
for alien life out there is a bit like
staring up into the night sky in the
hopes of spotting a gnat wearing the
world's tiniest spacesuit buzzing around
the moon
most of our efforts to find aliens focus
on radio waves because they're pretty
good at penetrating our atmosphere and
because we know alien technology might
produce them for the simple reason that
ours already does but even with some of
the most powerful radio antennas on the
planet the kind of radio leakage from
our own transmissions here on earth
would only be detectable a few light
years away which is less than the
distance to our nearest star proxima
centauri
and that's where dyson's fears come in
because if other civilizations have
already built them
we should be able to track them down and
from potentially
galaxy spanning distances
whilst the sphere itself probably
wouldn't be visible to us
the waste radiation emitted by a dyson
sphere probably would be as it would
look very very different to most other
stars
being heavily weighted towards the
infrared end of the spectrum this was
actually the point of freeman dyson's
little thought experiment in the first
place by the way he wasn't trying to
help mankind solve its future energy
woes he was brainstorming ways to track
down other intelligent civilizations in
the endless reaches of space
science is taking the possibility of
detecting dyson spheres seriously with
seti incorporating dyson's assumptions
into their search criteria and fermilab
in the u.s conducting their own search
based on data from an infrared specific
space telescope known as iris
for a couple of months back in 2015 we
even thought we'd found a dyson sphere
around what is now known as tabby's star
in the constellation cygnus
amateur astronomers noticed that tabby's
star appeared to have significantly
dimmed in the space of a single day
suggesting something large was somehow
obscuring part of the star
small fluctuations in a star's
luminosity aren't uncommon
but this was no small fluctuation a
planet the size of jupiter passing in
front of a star of this size would
reduce its luminosity by about one
percent
but
tabby's star
appeared to have dimmed by a staggering
22 percent
clearly whatever was obscuring it was
big
very big
a half-built dyson sphere perhaps
scientists were starting to get pretty
excited by this point and telescopes
around the world were trained on the
cygnus constellation where tabby's star
continued to display unusual behavior
and what exactly was causing tabby's
star to dim like some kind of stellar
disco ball
the truth is we still aren't quite sure
but sadly whilst there was genuine hope
this might have been humanity's first
sight of extraterrestrials and alien
megastructure seems to have fallen a
long way down the pecking order in terms
of potential hypotheses
with some kind of unusual ultra fine
dust cloud apparently the most likely
explanation so the search goes on and
unfortunately that may well be the case
for some time yet
the trouble is in reality a dyson's fear
is unlikely to be a solid
all-encompassing shell at all
instead it will probably be made up of a
mass of individual satellites commonly
in what is known as a dyson swarm this
kind of megastructure probably wouldn't
be able to tap into a hundred percent of
the star's energy
but it would be far more practical to
actually build than a shell ever could
be it would need far fewer resources
would be immeasurably simpler to
construct and would be more asteroid
proof and it could more easily be built
in stages over a period of hundreds even
thousands of years the problem from our
perspective is whilst the dyson swarm
would still dim the star around which it
was built the effect would be far less
dramatic than it would be with a dyson
shell
meaning we would be unlikely to be able
to detect one with our current
technology although if we're completely
honest that might not be such a terrible
thing
after all any civilization capable of
building a dyson sphere would be much
much more advanced than we are and it
might just be for the best if we don't
bump into each other
for a good while yet in some ways trying
to track down civilizations with their
know how to build a dyson sphere
is a little bit like a tiny fish
swimming around a vast ocean in the hope
of bumping into the megalodon
finding one would certainly be very
interesting but interesting in a kind of
soil yourself terrifying kind of way
thanks for watching
thanks again to stellaris galaxy command
for sponsoring this video make sure you
download and play today using the link
in the description below thank you